.
Let's solve some of the examples that have to do with the equations of lines that are
In typical form
In the past I have illustrated two pictures. They
Intersection of inclination, y
= mx + b
It is in fact this
This intersects the inclination
We saw the point of inclination in the last view
The y-value of y is taken on line
X = x x - x value
Line, when we have y value
The point x1, y1 is located on the line
This is an example of a tilt point model
Now we will talk about the typical shape
The typical format - let me type it here - is typical
Put all the x and y statements on
The left side of the equation
If we have ax + by = c
I want to emphasize that all of them
Different ways to write the same equation
If you give these, you can manipulate them geographically
So you get those or those
If you give these, you can get one or the other
They are all different ways of writing the same
Relationship, or the same line
So let's solve a bunch of examples
We have a line here
We have a written equation in the form of the intersection of inclination
The slope is 3, and the y-intersection is -8
Let's put it in a typical way
We have to get 3x on
The other side of the equation
The best way I can do this - let me rewrite
Equation, y = 3x - 8 - Let's ask
3x from both ends of the equation
If we put 3x on both sides, let's ask
3x, and ask 3x - what's left for us, in the right side of the
The equation?
The left side becomes 3x + y =
- 3x is deleted with -3x-- =
We finished
This is typical
The typical figure, I think is preferred when people are both
The two sides are located on the left side
But it is not used when we want to find the inclination
Intersection y
I do not know what the slope is and the intersection y when you see
In a typical form
The preferred form is the intersection of the slope, because it shows us
Precise inclination and intersection
The point of inclination, from the Saha find, you can look at it
Find the inclination
But y intersection, you have to make a simple effort up
Find it
But at least you can go straight from the tilt and
The point lies on it
But anyway, let's go from this equation, which is written
The point of inclination, and get it in the typical form
If we want to get it in the typical form, ie the same
Equation but typical form
And the good thing we'll do, let's distribute this, y
- 7 = -5 x, or -5x, +
-5 x-12 = 60
Now, we want to put all the variables on the left side
And all constants on the right side
Let us add 7 to both sides of this equation
+ 7 for both ends of equation
What do you become?
Well, -7 disappear, due to 7 + 7
And we have y =
5x + 67-
Now, if we want this x phrase to be on the left side, we can
We add 5x for both parties
Let's add 5x to the two sides of the equation
We'll get 5x = - these
Delete - 67
Now, we got the typical shape
If you want the format to be the same, you can
To rearrange them
Will be 5x + y = 67
We're done
Let us solve more of these examples
This is not a point of inclination nor
Model of intersection of inclination
It's kind of
Mixed shape
This part seems like a point of inclination, but it seems
As a different thing
It's not exactly a point of inclination
Let us see if we can manipulate them geographically until we transform them
For the typical shape
If we have 3y + 5
Let's distribute the 4
= 4x ​​- 36
Let us do exactly as we did in the last example
I used a different code as needed, so I explained to you
Different things
Instead of following this method, I will subtract 5
From both sides, but I will do it on the same line
I will subtract 5 from both parties
The left side of Equation 3y becomes
Because these two are deleted, this equals 4x
Then what is the result of 36 - 5?
= -41
Now we want x expressions to be on the right side
So let's subtract 4x from both ends of the equation
If -4x +, then -4x
What does the equation become?
Well, the left side stays 4x + 3y-
The right side, the reason I floated 4x is up
Delete it with those
We have 41
We're done
We got the typical shape
Now, let's go the other way
Let's start with some equations that are typical
We find their inclination and y intersection
The best way to know it is to find a tilt and
The intersection of y is to put the equation at the intersection of the inclination
If we want to make these equations
Y = mx + b
I will find the value of y
Let's do it
And the best thing to do here - let me rewrite it
5x - 2y = 15
Let's subtract 5x from both ends
If - 5x +, we have -5x
They are deleted
And we have -y
= 15 - 5x
Now, let's divide everything over -2
If we divide everything on -2, what will we get?
The left side becomes y
y = - 15 -2 -2 = -7.5
Then -5 -2 -2 - you can imagine
I am distributing the 1.2
I divide each of them on -2
If -5 -2 -2 = positive 2.5x
If you want to turn it into a cross-slope model
You can say that y = - you can
Reorder - 2.5x - 7.5
We want to find the inclination
he is here
This is the tendency
We want y intersection
In fact, let me relax
he is here
Which is -7.5
That is the intersection of y
Now this will be the format
Which we can represent the equation by
let's do it
Again, we'll need to find y
Let's subtract 3x from both parties
We get 6y = 25 - 3x
Then you can divide both sides on 6
The remaining y = 25/6 - 3/6
Or -1 / 2x
If you really want it, you have to rearrange it
y = -1 / 2x + 25/6
Where is the tendency?
Here is the tendency
1.2, that is the inclination
Where do you cross y?
This is the y intersection
Or is b
Point 0.25 / 6 lies on the line
Let's solve one another
We will solve one another
We have 9x - 9y = 4
For fun, let's begin by dividing the ends
Equation on 9
You do not have to do this
But it is somehow a fun way to
Transactions here automatically will become 1
If we divide the two ends of the equation to 9, then
Divided everything on 9, will become - in fact, well
Let's divide
Let's divide everything over 9
I do it for fun
This first phrase will become -x
The second phrase, we have -9.
-9, becoming positive y
Then the last phrase will become
4/9
Let me write this down
I'll leave some space here
Now, we want the x phrase to be on the right side, so let's add
x for the lateral equation
Let us add x for both ends of the equation
We delete this
The equation y = x - 4/9 becomes the equation
Where is the tendency?
The slope is the x expression coefficient
Ie that inclination = 1
Where do you cross y?
Intersection y here
He 4/9
.